NBC there's this thing called NBC now
it's a little unclear to me what it is I
guess it's like they're like they're
trying to be like young hip NBC or it's
their
lgbtq plus NBC something like that they
did a groundbreaking uh little piece
here on how trans people are struggling
to vote your voters are concerned they
might be blocked from casting their
ballots yeah that's because a growing
number of states are enforcing stricter
voter identification laws that
disproportionately impact the Community
NBC out reporter Joe your Caba joins us
now with more on this show good morning
to you so first of all how can voter ID
laws create obstacles for transgender
people and where do we see some of the
strictest voter ID laws
sure yes so voter ID law is
disproportionately impact trans people
because trans people are more likely to
have IDs without the name that they go
by and the gender marker that reflects
how they present and Recent research
shows that just over 200 000 eligible
trans voters in uh 31 states that both
conduct their elections mostly in person
and require or request ID at the polls
don't have IDs that reflect their gender
identities and the names they go by
um and you know the states that have the
strictest voter ID laws are mostly
concentrated in the South and Midwest so
you're you know Tennessee Wisconsin
Kansas so voters there God they have
everybody it's like there's all the
problems over here and they have
everybody looking over here constantly
having an ID that reflects who you
actually are is a key part of securing a
democracy every Western democracy has
this we are basically the only country
at this point in the Civilized world who
for some reason season a certain set of
our states have decided you do not need
an ID to vote when I voted last year in
the California recall election I've told
you this many times I tried to show the
guy my ID and he kind of freaked out all
they wanted to know was your name and
your address it's very bizarre because I
knew at the time my neighbor's name and
address and I suppose I could have gone
in the very next day and said I am him
or I am her and they would have had to
let me vote
um are these people implying that these
trans people that they're very worried
about can't get on planes because you
need to play you need an ID to get on a
plane which is of course the same thing
that they're constantly saying about
black people black people can't get IDs
I can't find one black person who hasn't
gotten an ID as I said yesterday it's
odd that CNN and MSNBC have not run
these videos of all of these black
people being turned away often I've seen
black people on planes have you guys
seen black people on planes every yeah
we've all seen black people on planes
they seem to be figuring it out they
these it's the soft bigotry of low
expectations these people are just
absolutely ridiculous and if
if you are an adult
who transitions so you're a biological
male let's say you're a 32 year old dude
and now you wish to live as a woman and
you transition whatever that means and
you'd go through whatever procedures and
you legally change your name and
everything else you get a new ID you get
a new ID so these people are just
creating problems it's like the whole
house is burning down and they're
worried about the Dust money in the
corner it is just so silly